nuova o brevi
chi vincerà la sfida questa volta gli
sfidanti di oggi sono sei pronta unita
[Applauso]
un applauso d'incoraggiamento per la sua
prima pochi in questa nuova challenge
pop hit trading challenge scambieremo
hip hop it
io contro il mio cagnolino berlino nello
scorso video vi ho detto stai meglio
raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace faremo
un'altra sola in gerwig ha raggiunto
invece per abete ha detto no buongiorno
e fantastici di se anche questo video
raggiunge sotto gli 11.000 mi piace ci
sarà un'altra sa legge
vediamo per i lavoratori lasciate mi
piace fa sotto mettetevi comodi prendete
i pop corn e iniziamo questa spalle con
berlino il cagnolino un gatto
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma non puoi accettare se non mi offre
nessun pop hit devi offrirmi un pochetto
in cambio di questo gatto quindi che
cosa mi offri a berlino dovresti tornare
al suo posto sarei d'anna non puoi
mangiare il pesce è il kite alto papa se
qualche problema tecnico in questa
partita per lino ai schiacciato avviato
ok siamo tornati accetto il pesce per il
gatto non riesco a resistere gli
occhioni di berlino e va bene accetto
tieni a te il gatto
a me il pesce primo turno contro dato
[Musica]
secondo round si offrono da una farfalla
so che a te piace rincorrere le farfalle
quindi questo papito che piacerà
tantissimo che cosa mi offri per questo
profit merlino il fiore per la farfalla
per sé intelligente merlino e va bene
accetto
prendo il fiore il seno per falla e tu
cosa mi offre adesso per il prossimo
turno un po pitt gufetto che carino ma
stai già chiedendo più pop hit non
teniamo aperto neanche uno cosa posso
offrirgli in cambio di quel pop hit gli
offro in cambio del buffetto una fragola
az sto per parlato decisione ne vuole di
più vuole un lato pop hit un cocco dai
dai una fragola europa drillo accetti ci
sta pensando
curiamo altri profit ti do un ananas e
un forte sviluppo che carino dai guarda
quanti pubbliche che tu prendo per
questo buffetto dai accetta berlino ci
sta pensando
secondo voi farà questo scambio o no ma
sembra che sia per premere il pulsante
più forse vuole ancora più pop hit
merlino stalle caso il flusso e di
assetto
evviva finalmente berlino accettato
altrimenti avrei dovuto dargli ancora
altri poppins tieni questi sono per te
tutti per te e io ho il momento prossimo
round ti offro un cupcake arcobaleno non
sei interessato a questo punto mi sembra
che cosa mi offri puntino sauro mio film
dinosauro per il cupcake
ottieni il caschetto e per te e io
prendo il dinosauro grazie io non riesco
a dire di no a berlino mi incanta con
quegli occhi e difficile chiesa di più
pop hit birri di no vediamo cosa mi
offriva adesso merlino miope 1 ma
multicolor che bello che cosa posso
offrirgli per in lana ti offro una
fragola arcobaleno non si mangia però e
allora accetti di cui di più e va bene
ma ti offro anche una goccia è un
unicorno lilla allora accetti
[Musica]
se ti va aiutato aspetta che nitido il
recapito equilibra prossimo turno nel
rino ha deciso di mettersi in gioco come
pop hit lui vuole essere un po bis da
scambiare sorella di scambio m che cosa
offro per il pop hit berlino o pro
greche hackett a pocket accetti di
essere scambiato per una cassetta pocket
prima shetty
beh hai ragione tu vali molto più di un
mini poppins per te berlino
io pratico ma è già rifiutato ma partono
bene e un cuore gigante po click bello
verdi offro l'arcobaleno accetti
[Musica]
però devi premere il pulsante accetto
altrimenti non vale ti offro anche un po
vedo che si illumina al buio guarda che
bello allora facchetti sì sì sì ancora
va bene vorrei dire che non potrò avere
marino pochi passiamo ora al prossimo
turno il nostro partecipante berlioz ha
deciso di cambiare posto
merlino offre un po pet gigante a
berlino ha deciso di nuovo di cambiare
voto ma mi ha offerto un po vederci
dante
che questa se stai prendendo vediamo
cosa potrei offrirle in cambio di questo
mega pocket ti offro tutti questi può
pezzi in cambio del tuo po pizze gigante
accetti stava per accettare ma ci sta
ancora pensando
il trio ti offro anche il cuore gigante
questi altri pochi tutti ancora quanti
sono accetti ancora vuole ancora pochi
il vostro anche questi due caffè guarda
quanti pop hit ti offro accetti o non
accetti ne vuole ancora cura al trip hop
it
ho un'idea merlino non potrei mai
rifiutare questo post perché questo può
pitt e il poveta forma di cane
allora non puoi rifiutare questa offerta
tutti questi bobby se questo cagnolino
allora accetti
ho accettato tutti questi pop hit sono
tuoi merino ecco qua e soprattutto il
cagnolino e io prendo questo poker
gigante ti piacciono a berlino piace un
sacco soprattutto il cagnolino e non si
mangia non si va già berlino e da si
vaglia cambiari lo hobbit
ecco a voi tutti i pof it che ha vinto
berline questa challenge stimi buono per
berlino
invece io impersonale già vinto un po
pitt gigante gufate dinosauro il pesce
mi sembra che abbiamo un vincitore molto
chiaro che queste challenge secondo me
chi ha vinto secondo me berlino ha fatto
un bel bottino dei popoli raccomando ha
lasciato un bel mi piace se volete
vedere un'altra challenge soprattutto se
volete vedere un'altra tra lenzi con
berlino che è bravissimo a giocare
tranne quando cerca di mangiare hip hop
it e ora mi lascia un po a quattro case
limits puoi cliccare per vedono i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
papini e buona visione